Das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir haben leider mit einem Mann weniger gespielt.
Mit einem Mann weniger, wie versteht man das?
Ohne Torwart.
Oh, Fehler, Golz, die große Möglichkeit.
Für einen Fußballspieler gibt es eigentlich immer nur eine Regel, das heißt, wichtig ist der nächste Ball, alles andere kannst du nicht mehr beeinflussen.
Einer der Kleinsten schraubt sich ganz hoch, Thomas Alof und die beste Reaktion vor der Pause von Richard Golz.
Also ich kann mir den Luxus erlauben, dass sich alle drei Vereine, bei denen ich gespielt habe oder zumindest unter Vertrag war, dass die schon sich mein Herz teilen können. Also wenn ich jetzt so zwölf Vereine hätte, wäre es ein bisschen schwer, aber mit den dreien kann ich gut leben. Alle Vereine spielen schon eine emotional starke Rolle bei mir. Sterbenkopf und Golz.
Wobei das mit den Stadien ja noch eine ganze Weile gedauert hat. Aber das andere kam früher, nämlich das Jahr 1992, beziehungsweise die Saison 1992-93. Das wurde so ein bisschen eine Zeitenwende im Fußball, jetzt so in der Retrospektive betrachtet. Nicht nur, weil Lechkov und Dotschev kamen zum HSV. Ich würde mal sagen, das Scouting hat im Jahr davor stattgefunden. Da habt ihr nämlich gegen ZSK Sofia in der UEFA Cup gespielt. Und da waren die nicht so schlecht. Danach waren sie beim HSV. Aber es gab drei Revolutionen, die mit dieser Saison einzughielten. Die eine war die Einführung der Rückpassregel. Dann wurde die Champions League eingeführt. Und mit Run gab es das erste Privatfernsehenübertragung. Das gab es vorher schon auch. Aber Run hat die Sportshow abgelöst. Und Reinhard Beckmann kam eben im roten Schakett die Treppe runter. Welche von diesen drei Revolutionen hat denn den Fußball deiner Meinung nach am meisten verändert?
Also die Einführung der Rückpassregel war eigentlich das Beste, was dem Fußball passieren konnte, weil vorher war es ja teilweise so langweilig. Du konntest das Spiel so verschleppen. Das Tempo war echt so unterdurchschnittlich und niedrig. Das Torwartspiel wurde von einem Tag auf den anderen deutlich anspruchsvoller.
Wie habt ihr euch darauf vorbereitet? War ich das vorher schon klar, als bekannt wurde, es wird diese Regeländerung geben?
Ja, so richtig nicht.
Aber es war ja im Grunde das erste Mal, dass man jetzt seine Füße richtig verwenden muss.
Klar, und da hat man natürlich ganz schnell die Unterschiede gesehen. Das wurde dann natürlich auch ein Element im Training, dass man dann viel mehr in das Mannschaftstraining mit einbezogen wurde oder eben auch einfach dann bestimmte Übungsformen dafür entwickelt wurde. Gott sei Dank war es zwar nicht beim HSV so, aber war es dann auch Aufgabe des Torwarttrainers. Das hätte eine sein können. Beim HSV war es einfach so, wie es dann auch vorher immer war. Du bist als Torwart da ganz normal in dem Training mitgelaufen und davon hast du dann auch profitiert.
Das heißt, du hattest dann auch mit Start der Saison, wo man das zum ersten Mal dann quasi in echt erlebt hat auf dem Feld, hattest du auch keine Probleme, dich umzustellen und jetzt eben quasi deine Füße aus dem laufenden Spiel heraus verwenden zu müssen?
Ja, wenn ich jetzt sage, ich hatte keine Probleme, damit wäre das sicherlich ein bisschen geschönt oder subjektive Wahrnehmung. Also ich würde schon sagen, das war nicht so einfach und da gab es sicherlich auch bessere mit den Füßen. Ganz so schlimm war es aber auch nicht.
Okay, eine schöne einerseits, andererseits Antwort. Und dann haben wir eben die Einführung der Champions League und die Einführung oder den Start von Ran als Berichterstatter über die Bundesliga. Und das hast du ja vorhin auch schon angerissen. Das hat eben ganz viel auch in der Wahrnehmung der Liga verändert. Wie hat dich das als Profifußballer betroffen? Lass mal mit Ran anfangen.
Also natürlich war das interessant zu sehen, wie der Fußball jetzt anders präsentiert wurde. Auch andere Berichterstattungen, Fragen und dann auch diese Sendung an sich viel moderner und peppiger präsentiert. Und dann gab es ja auch so Side-Events dazu, also irgendwelche Veranstaltungen. Es war die Zeit, wo es auch noch Hallenturniere gab im Winter. Und dann gab es halt einen so einen Endrundenturnier, so einen Masters.
Hallenmasters, genau.
Und dann gab es irgendwie die Ran-Fuchs-Party, die rund um dieses Turnier war. Du hast manchmal das Gefühl gehabt, du bist fast so ein kleiner Popstar. Also das war schon interessant zu sehen, wie sich Fußball so auf einmal, wie sich die Wahrnehmung und die Präsentation verändert.
Und wie bist du damit für dich umgegangen? Also eine der Änderungen war ja zum Beispiel, dass dann immer eine der Kameras auf die Tribüne gerichtet war. Man bekam immer ganz viele Reaktionen der Spielerfrauen und Spielerfrauen noch mal eingeblendet. Das hat da noch mal ein ganz anderes Genre eingeführt. Also die Instagram-Influencerinnen, die haben quasi ihre Vorvorgängerinnen, sind die Spielerfrauen zu Randzeiten. Und ich habe mir eben auch viele Spielberichte angeguckt, die man noch bei YouTube finden kann, von Spielen, bei denen du beteiligt warst, in der Hoffnung, dass ich etwas für mein Intro rausschneiden kann. Da hattest du eben einfach diese Sportschau-Berichte, die halt im langsamen Vortrag eines Versicherungsangestellten, einem darüber Informierten, dass in dieser Szene gerade ein schönes 4 zu 0 erzielt wurde. Und es gab eben Run, wo ich immer skippen musste zwischen den ganzen Szenen von irgendwelchen Frauen auf der Tribüne oder von Trainerreaktionen, bis ich da mal wieder eine Spielszene finden konnte. Wie hast du denn das wahrgenommen? Es war junger, aber wie hat es dich als Sportler beeinflusst?
Ich muss jetzt im Nachgang sagen, dass ich das gar nicht so wahrgenommen habe. Du hast damit ja dann eigentlich jede Woche zu tun. Ich habe das nicht so wahrgenommen. Natürlich merkst du irgendwie, da kommen jetzt andere Leute, stellen andere Fragen. Aber du gewöhnst dich relativ schnell daran. Das war natürlich schon alles ein bisschen interessanter und lebendiger. Das ging dann weiter. Die haben dann Statistiken geführt. Damals, als es noch Videotext gab, gab es dann auch so eine Rubrik. Du hast dann für jeden gehaltenen Ball irgendwie zehn Punkte gekriegt. Und nach jedem Spiel hast du den Fernseher angewacht und hast geguckt, wo stehe ich denn jetzt in der Rangliste? Wobei natürlich die Bewertung ja total subjektiv war. Und ob du jetzt irgendwie an dem…
Das kann auch einfach nur heißen, dass du eine sehr schlechte Abwehrreihe vor dir hast.
Es konnte alles heißen, aber du hast dich wahnsinnig gefreut, wenn du dann irgendwie in der Rangliste aufgestiegen bist. Also das ist natürlich schon ein Riesenunterschied gewesen. Auch einfach positiv irgendwie so. Aber ja, das wird alles ganz schnell normal.
Und was hat die Einführung der Champions League verändert, deiner Meinung nach? Du durftest ja noch nicht gleich dran teilnehmen. War dir auch insgesamt dann vergönnt. Aber du hast ja vorhin schon gesagt, Champions League-Ubertragung hast du vorhin schon genannt, als wir noch über Ende der 80er gesprochen haben. Das heißt, es ist ja in deinem Kopf vorhanden. Wie habt ihr das als Spieler wahrgenommen?
Ja, das war natürlich ein ganz aufregender Wettbewerb irgendwie, wo du sogar hast, da spielen nur die Besten der Besten von den Besten. Heute ist es ja auch wieder anders. Aber das war schon so. Also ich habe leider ja nicht Champions League spielen dürfen. Deswegen kann ich gar nicht sagen, wie das war oder wie das hätte sein können. Wäre toll gewesen. Aber das war schon ein Wettbewerb für Außerirdische im ersten Moment.
Weil eben da so über gute Mannschaften zusammen trafen und weil der Unterschied einfach war, dass die sich jetzt dann eben in einem geordneten Wettbewerb trafen, wo man auch dafür sorgen konnte, dass die Besten hinten raus sich treffen und das nicht so sein kann wie UEFA Cup oder Europapokal, der Landesmeister, erste Runde gegen irgendeinen tschechischen Pokalsieger und auf einmal bist du draußen, weil du zwei schlechte Tage hattest.
Genau und also ich habe ja jetzt, bis auf die Anfangszeit, wo wir noch eine gute Mannschaft waren oder wo der HSV noch zur Spitze gehörte und immer mal ein paar Außereisern nach oben hatte, aber das war halt nicht meine Kategorie so ungefähr. Und deswegen, das hat sich ja dann auch relativ schnell, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, auch verwässert. Die Champions League wurde ja dann auch ein bisschen aufgebläht und dann haben halt nicht nur die Landesmeister da gespielt, aber am Anfang war es ja, glaube ich, wirklich so, dass nur die Meister da gespielt haben und ja, das war schon weit entfernt von mir.
Genau, die Meister und dann gab es ja noch den Europapokal, der Pokalsieger. Am Anfang gab es den, glaube ich, noch begleitend. Wir haben jetzt kurz übersprungen, den Abschied von Volker Schock, der entlassen wurde. In der Saison vorher war das. Das war auch so eine Saison, wo es nicht ganz so gut für dich verlief. Ich komme da deswegen darauf zurück, weil du später mal gesagt hast, dass das für dich mit eines der schwersten Erlebnisse gewesen wäre. Vor allem, weil du dann auch wegen einer Verletzung selbst nicht helfen konntest. Du hast mal gesagt in der Interview, du saßt heulend in der Kabine, als Volker Schock entlassen wurde.
Ja, ich habe mir da, glaube ich, die Hand gebrochen. Oder ein Finger. Ich glaube, es war der kleine Finger beim Auswärtsspiel bei den Stuttgarter Kickers. Und klar, Volker Schock war für mich eben schon das Symbol meiner, also der Stand, der war halt die Personifizierung meines glücklichen Lebenswandels. Ohne ihn wäre ich nicht da gewesen, wo ich dann war. Er war auch einfach ein guter Mensch und ich mochte ihn persönlich einfach auch unheimlich gerne. Und man hat ihm auch über Wochen schon angesehen, wie er in der Situation gelitten hat. Und wenn es dann zu Ende geht, ich war echt tief berührt und habe da schon wirklich die ein oder andere Träne vergossen.
Und jetzt kommen wir in eine interessante Phase deiner Karriere. Bisher lief alles eigentlich reibungslos im Schlepptau des sportlichen Abschneidens des HSV. Aber du hattest deine Stammkeeper-Position sicher. Du durftest mal UEFA Cup spielen. Im DFB-Pokal gab es einige interessante Spiele. Man könnte allein, wenn man die Kader-Namen nennt, wer da alles bei euch gespielt hat. Also zur Saison 1993-94 kam dann Ewan Nausgas, Carsten Beron drehte richtig auf, Jörg Alberts war auf einmal da, Jan Furtug war vorher die ganzen Jahre da, ist dann zur Eintracht gelaufen. Also allein da könnte man eine Stunde mit dir drüber reden. Aber es gab dann auch die Phase in der Saison 1994-95 unter dem Trainer Benno Müllmann, der dein ehemaliger Mitspieler war, dass du auf einmal wieder Ersatzkeeper kam. Und wer war da auf einmal wieder im Tor? Der von Eintracht Frankfurt entlassene 39-jährige Uli Stein. Wie ist das abgelaufen? Wann hast du erfahren, dass Uli Stein wieder zum HSV kommt? Und was hat das mit dir gemacht, die Frage wollte ich schon immer mal stellen.
Ja, die Information kam relativ spät am Ende der Saison. Irgendwann, wie das dann so damals war, stand in der Zeitung, Uli Stein kommt wieder in Hamburg zurück. Und so habe ich gedacht, das ist ja sehr lustig. Und habe es jetzt im ersten Moment nicht für ernst genommen. Benno wollte damit dann auch mich ein bisschen kitzeln, weil er mit meiner Leistung in der Saison nicht zufrieden war.
Hatte dir das so offen gesagt oder interpretierst du das so?
Nein, das hat er mir dann gesagt. Weil irgendwann ließ es sich nicht mehr verheimlichen oder irgendwann war es dann auch klar. Und dann hat er gesagt, nein, das stimmt schon. Wir haben da irgendwann mal ein Gespräch geführt. Und dann habe ich gesagt, du bist ja nicht ganz dicht. Habe ich mir gedacht. Ich habe es so nicht gesagt.
Kann man auch mit einem ehemaligen Mitspieler als Trainer nicht so offen sprechen? Schon eine besondere Situation, oder?
Ja, du kannst natürlich anders mit ihm sprechen. Das war ja auch so, Benno Müller hat den Spieler gesiezt, so wie Otto Rehagel das auch gemacht hat. Er war dann natürlich hier unter einem Dilemma, weil er eben auch Spieler hatte, mit denen er selber schon gespielt hat. Und da hat er dann wirklich gesagt, ich kann euch nicht sitzen. Das ist ja Quatsch. Und das ist natürlich doof. Wenn du Trainer bist und den einen siehst, den anderen dudst du und so. Also wir haben uns gedudst. Und ja, ich war damit nicht ganz zufrieden damit, weil mir natürlich klar war, wenn er ihn holt, dann lässt er ihn auch spielen. Und das hat dann auch über weite Teile der Saison stattgefunden. Dann hat Uli Stein aber auch die eine oder andere Verletzung gehabt. Dann habe ich am Ende der Saison wieder ein paar Spiele gemacht. Und dann war es so, als Uli Stein dann wieder gesund war, hat sich Benno dann für mich entschieden. Das war dann der Moment, wo Uli Stein dann auch nicht mehr ganz so zufrieden war. Und dann ist das wieder so ein bisschen im Argen geendet. Ja, also ich muss auch im Nachhinein sagen, die Saison war jetzt auch nicht so überragend. Und im Endeffekt kam es dann vielleicht so, oder kam das so, was Benno sich so vorgestellt hat, dass das dann zu einer besseren Leistung führt.
Aber war der Uli Stein, den du dann da getroffen hast im Jahr 1994, 1995 ein anderer als der, von dem du dich verabschiedet hast, nachdem er die Cobra ausgenockt hatte 1987?
Also ich hatte am Anfang meiner Karriere, als ich mit ihm zusammengearbeitet hatte, war das Verhältnis auch gut. Also wir haben nicht so viel miteinander zu tun gehabt, weil irgendwie er hat mich nicht so wahrgenommen. Aber das Verhältnis war einfach gut und problemfrei. Es war dann auch gut, als er wieder zurückkam, weil Uli Stein dann auch am Ende seiner Karriere auch zu mir gesagt hat, du hör mal, ich weiß, was du jetzt denkst vielleicht, aber nimm die Situation an und dann kannst du auch davon profitieren. Das fand ich auch gut und wir haben dann auch ein gutes Verhältnis gehabt. In den Jahren dazwischen war das Verhältnis nicht so gut, weil immer, wenn er nach Hamburg kam zum Beispiel, weil das hat ihn ja gewurmt, dass er nicht mehr beim HSV war. Der HSV ist schon sein Herzensverein gewesen, er hat da seine schönste Zeit gehabt. Und dass ich dann sein Nachfolger war, das hat ihn gewurmt. Und es gab manchmal Spiele, da hat er mich mit dem Arsch nicht angeguckt. Da hat er mir einfach deutlich gezeigt, was er von mir hält, weil er dieses Spiel unbedingt gewinnen wollte. Also es war dann so, okay, kann man machen, muss man aber nicht. Und dann später war es wieder total okay. Das zeichnet ihn auch so ein bisschen aus, dass er auch sehr wechselhaft sein kann. Aber das hat bei ihm einfach nochmal dazu geführt, er war dann in jedem Spiel so super konzentriert. Das war halt so ein bisschen seine Masche.
Aber wie ist es, wenn man dann plötzlich wieder Ersatzkeeper ist und als Torhüter ist man ja nochmal in der besonderen Position, dass Gegentore gegen den eigenen Verein vielleicht dann doch ja gar nicht mehr so schlimm sind?
Ja, das ist auch eher hypothetisch. Im Nachhinein denkst du das dann vielleicht, aber in der Situation, wenn du auf der Bank sitzt und du siehst deine Kollegen, wie sie das Spiel verlieren, dann leidest du schon auch mit. Auch wenn du dann vielleicht denkst, naja, vielleicht führt es dazu, dass ich jetzt doch wieder spiele. Aber ich konnte mich mit so einem Verhalten nicht so anfreunden, weil so eine Situation, dass die Mannschaft verliert, ist immer kacke. Ob du nur auf dem Platz stehst oder nicht, das führt nicht dazu, dass die Situation sich verbessert.
Okay, aber es muss dich doch wahnsinnig gemacht haben, dass du auf einmal wieder auf der Bank sitzt. Ich stelle mir dieses Bundesliga-Profi-Sein schon auch ein bisschen vor wie eine Droge. Du hast diesen Adrenalinrausch, auch diesen unglaublichen Stress, auf dem Platz zu stehen im Fokus von zigtausenden, wenn es übertragen wird, Millionen von Menschen. Und so sehr das eine Belastung sein kann, so schön ist das auch. Dann bist du auf einmal derjenige, der zwar schon irgendwie noch mit ins Stadion reinlaufen darf, aber der halt auf der Bank sitzt.
Ja klar, also das fühlt sich alles auf einmal ganz, ganz anders an. Also dir fehlt dieser Adrenalinkick total. Du fährst nach Hause, freust dich, wenn die Mannschaft gewinnt. Bist auch traurig, wenn sie verliert. Aber das ist alles ein ganz anderes Level. Zwar einer, der ein bisschen näher dran sitzt, aber du bist im Endeffekt Zuschauer. Und das Spiel an sich macht dir auch einfach Spaß. Also es geht ja auch darum, zu spielen, weil man Spaß am Spiel hat.
Also Uli Stein, er war da kurz da. Du warst dann wieder im Tor am Ende der Saison. Er ist dann zu Bielefeld gegangen. Allein über das DFB-Pokalspiel in der ersten Runde der nächsten Saison könnte man eine ganze Sendung machen. Da hat nämlich dann Uli Stein mit Bielefeld gegen Richard Golz mit dem HSV 2 zu 1 gewonnen. Das sind jetzt Momente, da kann ich mir auch schon dran erinnern. Da wurde damals ein großes Thema drum gemacht. Der größere Kontext der kommenden Saison, 1995-96, war aber dann der, dass Benno Müllmann nach einem ganz fürchterlichen Start mit zwei Niederlagen und sechs Unentschieden aus den ersten acht Spielen entlassen wurde. Und es kam Felix Magath, der erst Manager beim HSV war, später dann Co-Trainer unter Müllmann und jetzt Trainer. Wenn wir im Jahr 2019 über Felix Magath sprechen, dann hat er ein Image auch als Trainer. Zum einen der Quelix und zum anderen hat er aber auch dieses Schachtdenker-Image so ein bisschen vielleicht auch etabliert und mag das ganz gerne, dass er auch als der Denker dargestellt wird. Wie war denn das damals im Jahr 1995?
Ich hatte mit Felix Magath schon relativ viel zu tun, weil er Co-Trainer war vorher bei Benno Müllmann. Und ich immer montags mit ihm, also da war er mein Torwarttrainer, da habe ich mit ihm dann immer extra trainiert. Also eins zu eins. Felix hat auch gesagt, du sagst mir, was wir machen sollen und ich schieße dir die Bälle um die Ohren. Weil er kannte sich auch nicht.
Und es waren richtige Bälle und keine Medizinbälle.
Wir hatten auch einen Medizinball dabei, aber in der Regel war das Torwarttraining auch mit echten Bällen. Und dann, klar, wenn man wirklich nur zu zweit trainiert, macht man ja auch mal eine Pause und unterhält sich. Und da habe ich schon so ein bisschen gehört, wie so seine Denkweise ist. Und er war Trainer der Amateurmannschaft. Und mit den Spielern hat man sich ja auch mal ausgetauscht. Und da war es auch so, die haben dann wirklich Geschichten erzählt, die ich dann ja später auch erlebt habe. Und da hast du so gedacht, das kann eigentlich nicht sein, aber das macht er wahrscheinlich mit der Amateurmannschaft. Kann man das ja machen, oder?
Was zum Beispiel?
Ewig lange trainieren und einfach schleifen, bis der Arzt kommt. Und die haben auch am Anfang der Saison alles weggeschossen. Die sind dann am Ende irgendwie eingebrochen, weil sie wahrscheinlich kräftemäßig das nicht durchgehalten haben. Oder einfach dann, weiß ich nicht, vom Kopf müde waren. Aber die sind in die Saison gestartet, haben eine richtig gute Saison gespielt. Und das kam ja dann bei uns, das ist ja immer so der Effekt gewesen. Na ja, und dann war irgendwann der Tag da, wo Felix Magath Cheftrainer wurde und da habe ich so gedacht, so Jungs, jetzt geht's los. Ich weiß genau, was passiert.
Du wusstest als Einziger, was auf die Mannschaft sich kommt.
Nicht als Einziger, aber die anderen haben es vielleicht auch geahnt, weil, wie gesagt, man hat das dann von der Amateurmannschaft gehört. Aber klar, dass er das so eins zu eins umsetzt, das hat keiner erwartet.
Und war das damals Mitte der 90er auch eine besondere Qualität? Oder gab es damals auch andere Trainer? Also Ende der 70er hat man mit Merkel einen Trainer gehabt, gegen den haben die Bayern-Spieler reportiert, als es hieß, der soll zu den Bayern kommen. Der hatte auch so ein strenges Image. Da ging es aber weniger darum, die Spieler körperlich über ihre Grenzen immer wieder hinwegzuführen, sonst ging es um Menschenführung. Ernst Happel war jetzt auch nicht derjenige Trainer, der ums Eck gekommen ist und gesagt hat, hey Richie, schön dich zu sehen. Und wie geht es der Familie und den Kindern? Der hatte auch eine andere Ansprache. War Felix Magath damals auch ein besonderer Fall innerhalb der Bundesliga-Trainer?
Da gab es noch Werner Lorand, dem man so ein ähnliches Verhalten nachgesagt hat. Das kann ich jetzt aber nicht beurteilen, weil ich unter dem nicht trainiert habe. Ich glaube, der Erfolg kam ja relativ schnell. Er hat sich ja schnell eingestellt. Dann wurde da vielleicht auch hier und da mal mehr daraus gemacht. Wenn du in der Mühle drin bist, gewöhnt man sich relativ schnell dran. Aber klar gab es einfach zu viele Phasen, wo du am Ende der Woche gedacht hast, ich habe ganz schön schwere Beine. Wie soll das am Wochenende gehen? Und dann ging es ja doch irgendwie.
Der sportliche Erfolg war da. Am Ende der Saison mit einem 4 zu 1 auswärts in Frankfurt sprang der HSV. Am letzten Spieltag dann auf einen UEFA Cup-Platz, das heißt, der Saison drauf hat der UEFA Cup gespielt. Es gab aber zwei merkwürdige Spiele, die dich betreffen in dieser Spielzeit 95, 96. Und zwar einmal ein 5 zu 1 zu Hause gegen Eintracht Frankfurt, wo der HSV nach 31 Minuten schon 4-0-4 hat. Und in der 75. Minute schießt du ein Eigentor und wirst in der 87. Minute ausgewechselt. Echt? So ist es notiert. Dann muss es ein Eigentor gewesen sein. Ich habe auch keine Bilder dazu gefunden.
Ich wurde ausgewechselt.
Aber ich kann dich an die Outtakes erinnern. Der Ersatzkeeper und ich habe mich gefragt, ob das damals der Felix Magath Signature Move war, wenn er 5 zu 1 gegen ein Team gewinnt, so wie er es dann später mit Bayern und Wolfsburg gemacht hat, dass er dann sagt, hier, ich kann sogar den Torhüter wechseln. Aber das heißt, es ist jetzt für dich kein so besonderes Spiel, dass du mir jetzt da alles zu erzählen kannst.
Also jetzt, wo du es sagst, kommt so eine ganz, ganz, ganz dunkle Erinnerung. Aber ich wüsste jetzt nicht, wer für mich eingewechselt wurde. Wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein Amateur.
Das werde ich gleich nachreichen. Was du mir aber dann auf jeden Fall daran wirst du dich noch erinnern, ist das Spiel in Rostock. Da hast du nämlich nicht nur auf deiner Position gespielt. Das stimmt. Und eingewechselt für dich wurde, also du wirst als Eigentorgeber zum 4 zu 1.
Ah ja, der Ball sprang von der Latte an meinen Oberschenkel und dann ins Tor.
Siehst du, so kommt es nämlich zurück. Holger Himann. Ok, aber dann haken wir ab. Keine größere Geschichte dahinter. Aber dieses Auswärtsspiel in Rostock, da hast du nicht nur als Torhüter gespielt.
Ja, da war die Situation vor dem Spiel so, dass wir hatten einige kranke, verletzte Spieler. Es standen nicht allzu viele mehr zur Verfügung für das Spiel am Wochenende. Und von den Regularien war es damals so, dass du, glaube ich, nur zwei oder drei Vertragsamateure im Kader haben durftest. Also wir hatten echt ein großes Problem, genug Leute auf den Platz zu kriegen oder auf den Spielberichtsbogen. Und dann kam Felix Magath, der mit dieser Maßnahme auch ein bisschen gegenüber dem DFB protestieren wollte oder darauf hinweisen wollte, dass eben das Quatsch ist. Und meinte so, du, wenn es das Spiel hergibt und wir vielleicht irgendwie nochmal nachlegen müssen, dann was hältst du davon? Oder würdest du das machen? Und dann habe ich gesagt, naja, gut, ich habe im Leben nicht dran gedacht, dass es dazu kommt, aber habe gesagt, ja, okay, Trainer, machen wir. Und dann wurde sogar noch schon ein Trikot für mich vorbereitet. Das hatte aber dann die falsche Farbe. Und dann kam es nämlich dazu, dass das Trikot, mit dem ich gespielt habe, wurde dann überklebt. Also ich hatte dann so ein gebasteltes Trikot an. Sah nicht besonders gut aus.
Hattest du auch nicht so wirklich viele Chancen, so ganz kleine?
Wenn ich ein bisschen schneller gewesen wäre, dann hätte ich vielleicht einmal nicht im Abseits gestanden. Also so eine halbe Halbchance habe ich gehabt, genau. Hat sich nicht rentiert. War ein stiller Protest von Felix Magath. Und wir haben das Spiel, glaube ich, 2-0 verloren.
Genau, das ging 2-0 aus und er hat gesagt, ich wollte versuchen, ob vielleicht noch was geht. Und das war dann ein kurzes Auftreten für ein paar Minuten als Stürmer. Diese Saison ging in den UEFA Cup. In der nächsten Saison 1996-1997, faszinierende Zeit, Jörg Alberts ging damals zu den Rangers, Lechkov zu Marcel, Karsten Kober hat den Verleih zu Hertha verlassen. Ich vermute, dass es auch ein Wechsel war, der für dich auch eine Bedeutung hatte, weil ihr einfach so lange zusammen gespielt habt und aus einer ähnlichen Altersklasse kommt. Im DFB-Pokal lief es ganz gut und auch im UEFA Cup erst gegen Monaco ausgeschieden, aber in der Bundesliga, da lief es richtig schlecht für den HSV. Nach einem 0-4 gegen Köln am 32. Spieltag seid ihr abgerutscht bis auf den 15. Tabellenplatz. Damals gab es noch keine Relegation, das heißt, 16. Tabellenplatz wäre Abstieg gewesen. Felix Magath wurde auf einer – wie man jetzt im Nachhinein hört – legendären Grillparty von Uwe Seele, der damals HSV-Präsident war, entlassen. Und Ralf Schär hat die Saison dann zu Ende gebracht. Es gab in diesem Jahr aber auch ein denkwürdiges Derby von dir gegen den FC St. Pauli. Und da haben wir im Intro nämlich auch einen Ausschnitt von gehört. Soll ich es erzählen oder möchtest du?
Ich kann mich nicht mehr daran erinnern.
Das könnte tatsächlich in diesem Fall so sein. Also in der 85. Minute schießt der HSV das 2 zu 1 im Derby gegen St. Pauli. Dann gibt es einen Befreiungsschlag von dir. Ich weiß nicht, ob es ein Pass sein sollte. Der landet direkt bei einem St. Pauli-Spieler. Das war der Russe Pisarev. Der liegt quer zu Scharping. Der macht das 2 zu 2. Mich interessiert das Spiel jetzt nicht, weil ich darauf hinweisen möchte, du hast mal einen Fehler gemacht in deiner Karriere. Mich interessiert es, weil es eben im Derby war gegen den St. Pauli. Und ich mir die Frage gestellt habe, wie war es denn damals? Da sind wir jetzt quasi in der zweiten Hälfte der 90er. Was muss man sich in Hamburg anhören, wenn man so ein Derby gefühlt verliert?
Wenn ich jetzt auf meine Karriere zurückblicke, dann muss man wirklich sagen, das war der absolute Tiefpunkt. Oder das war echt der Worst Case definitiv, weil die Saison war eben ein bisschen holprig, fing ganz ordentlich an, aber nach hinten raus echt kacke.
Aber schlimmer als die Abstiege mit Freiburg?
Na ja, das sind ja andere Voraussetzungen gewesen. In Freiburg war es ja durchaus denkbar, dass man absteigt, beim HSV natürlich nicht. Und wenn die Erwartungen in Hamburg immer hoch gewesen sind, ist es schon vergleichbar. Natürlich abzusteigen aus der Bundesliga ist nochmal was anderes und finde ich deutlich schmerzhafter, als wenn du mit dem HSV nicht die Quali für den UEFA Cup schaffst. Aber so ein Abstieg tut schon richtig weh. Aber dieses Spiel war natürlich ein Derby in Hamburg. Wir haben das Spiel zwar nicht verloren, aber haben eben das Spiel nicht gewonnen. Kurz vor Schluss, durch so eine Aktion, das wird mir heute noch erzählt. Und zwar nicht mehr so vorgeworfen, aber das sind so Sachen, die vergisst niemand. Also kein Fan, kein Internet vor allen Dingen, keine Datenbank.
Nein, dieses Spiel findet man auch noch.
Kein Podcast, vergisst das. Und klar, damit ist eine ganze Menge kaputtgegangen, irgendwie so in der Wahrnehmung. Weil bis dahin hatte ich eigentlich, glaube ich, ein ganz gutes Standing in Hamburg. Und das war dann schon dadurch ein bisschen eingetrübt.
Und wie waren Derbys damals generell? Ihr hattet viel mehr Spiele gegen Werder Bremen, was ich jetzt auch mal als Derby klassifizieren würde. Gegen St. Pauli hat immer wenigstens St. Pauli mal in der ersten Liga gespielt. Du hast 87 Jahre angefangen. 1983 gab es den Fall von einem getöteten Werder-Fan am Rande eines Derbys. Wie waren denn damals die Derbys? War da Gewalt ein Thema? War das eine Rivalität, die vor allem über die Medien stattgefunden hat? Wie hast du das als unmittelbar Beteiligter wahrgenommen?
Also ich hatte das Gefühl tatsächlich am Anfang, das ist natürlich ein Derby und eine Rivalität, aber bei weitem nicht so, wie es jetzt dargestellt wird oder wie es jetzt ist. Also das hat sich in meiner Wahrnehmung speziell in den letzten zehn Jahren oder vielleicht seit, sagen wir mal, Anfang der 2000er, also vielleicht doch schon ein bisschen länger, aber bis zu dem Zeitpunkt, an dem ich zum Beispiel nach Bremen, nach Freiburg gegangen bin, also 1998, ja, war das ein Derby, aber es war jetzt für mich gefühlt nicht größer als gegen St. Pauli oder irgendwie aggressiver oder so. Ich habe so eher das Gefühl, ob das hat sich dann…
Woher kommt denn dann das?
Weiß ich nicht, sicherlich höhere Berichterstattung oder größere Berichterstattung. Mehr Leute, die sich mit dem Thema auseinandersetzen. Fußball eben durch die Berichterstattung, eine größere Plattform in den Medien. Du hast es ja heute auch, finde ich, dass du natürlich auch immer noch Gewalt hast in den Stadien, rund um die Stadien. Ich glaube aber, dass die Leute, die mit dem Fußball was zu tun haben, weniger oder dass der Anteil höher wird an Leuten, die gar nicht irgendwie dem Fußballumfeld zuzuordnen sind, dass da auch so ein bisschen Krawalltourismus gibt oder dass das auch als Plattform genutzt wird, um Aufmerksamkeit zu erwecken. Und dann ist ein Derby natürlich auch nochmal eine andere Möglichkeit. Und irgendwie habe ich auch so das Gefühl, durch diese ganze Globalisierungsgeschichte, Support your local team spielt eine sehr viel größere Rolle. Der Fußball nimmt einen größeren Platz ein, finde ich, für viele Leute als einziges Medium der Bestätigung, wo man sozusagen seine Freude rauszieht. Und das verteidigen die Leute jetzt vielleicht anders oder intensiver oder fühlen sich bedrohter durch die anderen, obwohl das war auch ein bisschen mein Problem. Ich habe nie einen Hehl daraus gemacht, dass ich eigentlich ganz froh bin, dass St. Pauli auch da ist. Und das kam dann natürlich in diesem Worst-Case-Szenario dann doppelt zum Tragen, weil derby ist für so eine Stadt das Schönste, was es gibt. Ich habe immer gesagt, Leute, seid doch froh, dass St. Pauli, dass wir das Derby in der ersten Liga spielen können. Einmal ein Auswärtsspiel weniger. Ihr müsst nicht irgendwie nach Wattenscheid fahren zum Beispiel. Seid doch froh. Ich freue mich auch darüber, dass ich in Hamburg spielen kann. Und so ein Derby, das eine Woche vorher und eine Woche danach bestimmt das auch ganz viel das Leben in der Stadt. Das ist das Schönste, was es gibt. Natürlich ist wichtig, und das ist auch mir wichtig gewesen, dass der HSV vor St. Pauli steht, dass wir sich schlagen. Aber ich finde es gut, dass sie da sind. Das wurde mir so oft danach ausgelegt, als St. Pauli-Sympathisant. Es gab Leute, die haben gesagt, es kursiert in das Gerät, ich hätte einen St. Pauli-Aufkleber am Auto und ein Tattoo. Damit hat sich damals niemand tätowieren lassen.
Und du erst recht.
Nein, heute noch nicht.
Kein St. Pauli-Tattoo am Körper von Richard Golz, aber zu dieser Zeit vielleicht auch kein HSV-Tattoo mehr. Wir gehen jetzt aus der Saison 96-97, wo der Abstieg vermieden werden konnte. Aber Felix Magath durfte in die Saison 97-98 nicht mehr Trainer sein. Du hast gesagt, dass du anders wahrgenommen wurdest nach diesem Fehler im Derby gegen St. Pauli. Hat das dann auch damit zu tun, dass zu 97-98 ein richtiger Umbruch beim HSV stattgefunden hat und auch die Torhüterposition betroffen war? Also es kam Frank Pagisbov als Trainer, es kamen unglaublich viele Spiele. Anthony Yeboah, Rodolfo Cardoso, Jacek Dembinski, Thomas Graveson, Ingo Hertsch, Andreas Zeyer, aber eben auch Sasa Ilic von Pusan Davo, zweite koreanische Liga und wichtiger vielleicht noch Hansjörg Budt, 23 Jahre alt, damals vom VfL Oldenburg. War dir da klar, dass es da um deine Position geht und dass er dich ersetzen würde? Oder wie wurde dir das kommuniziert?
Ja, es war schon – oder ich glaube, Felix Magath hatte es schon – auch den Gedanken gefasst. Der war ja dann nicht mehr Trainer, aber er hat ja schon die Planung für die neue Saison sicherlich mitgestaltet. Meine Saison war ja auch nicht so gut. Die fing ganz gut an, aber nach hinten raus war es dann wirklich nicht mehr gut. Die Mannschaft hat auch nicht mehr so richtig gut funktioniert. Es gab dann eben auch noch so zwei Lager, weil die einen waren genervt davon, dass sie immer kaputt waren. Es gab eine Fraktion, die meinetwegen für und eine, die gegen den Trainer war. Die einen haben gesagt, wir können es nicht ändern, wir müssen hier weiterziehen. Die anderen haben gesagt, wir waren ein bisschen am Lamentieren. Also die Stimmung war schlecht und ich war Kapitän in der Situation in dem Jahr und stand so ein bisschen dazwischen.
Das war auch Felix Magath damals bewusst. Er hat auf dieser legendären Grillparty zu Uwe Seeler angeblich gesagt, zwei Spieler, Spörl und Kmetch, glaube ich, will er aussortieren und dann mit hartem Training die letzten beiden Spiele gewinnen. Und Uwe Seeler war wohl so, dass er ihm erstmal mitgesagt hat, super Idee, so machen wir das und musste dann von den anderen Anwesenden des ASV-Vorstands daran erinnert werden, dass die Grillparty eigentlich dazu angesetzt worden war, Felix Magath zu entlassen, der auch schon mit seinem Anwalt zu dieser Grillparty gekommen war. Also völlig irre, wenn das alles so stimmt.
Da weißt du tatsächlich mehr als ich. Ja, also wie gesagt, ich habe nicht gut gespielt zum Ende der Saison. Felix Magath hat mich aber auch nicht aus dem Tor genommen. Also er wusste, dass ich schon versucht habe, für ihn zu kämpfen. Oder auch einfach der Meinung war, das macht keinen Sinn, über einen Trainer nachzudenken. Wir müssen einfach Gas geben, auch wenn das jetzt vielleicht alles nicht so toll ist. Ja, und da hat er aber den Transfer von Jörg Budt auch entweder mit initiiert, aber es war seine Idee oder er hat dem eine Zustimmung gegeben. Und dann war er nicht mehr Trainer und Frank Pagelsdorf hat dann in Vorbereitung der neuen Saison dann unbedingt einen neuen Torwart haben. Das habe ich auch von anderen Kollegen gehört, die nämlich von ihm oder von einem Berater angesprochen wurden, hier will es nicht zum HSV kommen, die wollen unbedingt einen neuen Torwart haben. Also mir war schon klar, spätestens in der Sommerpause, da wird sich irgendwie was tun. Große Konkurrenz. Jörg Budt hatte niemand so richtig auf dem Zettel. Der kam eben aus Oldenburg und eigentlich der Königstransfer von Pagelsdorf war Sascha Illich aus Korea.
Cousin Davo.
Auch ein guter Junge, aber stellte sich dann relativ schnell raus, dass er nicht die Verstärkung ist, die sich der Trainer vorgestellt hat. Dann blieb nur noch Jörg Budt und er hat es auch einfach gut gemacht, muss man ja sagen. Seine Karriere war ja auch außerordentlich gut. Ja, und dann war für mich klar, okay, dieses eine Jahr, nachdem dann am Anfang klar war, dass ich nicht spiele, muss ich jetzt irgendwie noch gestalten bzw. muss halt jetzt mal gucken, dass es dann auch nach der langen Zeit vielleicht auch der richtige Moment ist, mal was anderes zu machen. Ich hatte die Möglichkeit, im Winter zu wechseln. Da gab es mehrere Möglichkeiten. Einmal war Sporting Gijon interessiert. Die sind dann danach abgestiegen. Das war auch gut, da nicht hinzuwechseln. Der Transfer hat sich zerschlagen. Die andere Option war im Winter tatsächlich Tottenham. Als Christian Groß da Trainer war, da habe ich schon gedacht, boah, das wäre jetzt mal wirklich eine tolle Sache, der Hass auf hat. Leider gesagt, nee ist nicht, du musst bleiben. Da war ich natürlich in dem Moment extrem enttäuscht. Bin dann ja zur neuen Saison nach Freiburg gegangen. Das war natürlich auch eine tolle Entscheidung. Es war eine absolut tolle Zeit in Freiburg. Natürlich ist es nicht vergleichbar mit England oder Tottenham. Wer weiß, wie es da gelaufen wäre. Aber Freiburg war eine tolle Zeit. Von daher bin ich da jetzt nicht so böse. So oder so wäre es gut gewesen für die Familie. Das war toll in Freiburg. Wir sind da alle zusammen gewesen. Die Kinder sind da groß geworden in einer professionellen Umgebung mit tollen Menschen, die jetzt zum Teil auch noch da sind. Also das, was man von einem Verein im Optimalfall haben will, wird da ganz viel geboten. Wir sind natürlich auch ein- zweimal abgestiegen in der Zeit. Aber so zum Arbeiten war das toll. Arbeiten und Leben in der Kombination war unschlagbar.
Aber jetzt macht man nicht das Kapitel Freiburg zu, bevor ich es aufgemacht habe. Vorher müssen wir das HSV-Kapitel beschließen. Da würden mich zwei Sachen interessieren. Zum einen, was du zum wiederholten Mal inzwischen in der Situation, dass du dich behaupten musstest. Nachdem sich das mit Zaza Elic dann nicht so als der Königstransfer herausgestellt hat, sondern man eben dieses Torhütertalent gesehen hat, was du jetzt ein bisschen in der Rolle wie Uli Stein damals als du kamst. Wie hast du versucht, diesen Konkurrenzkampf zu gestalten?
Also ich habe eigentlich von meiner Seite aus in all den Jahren immer versucht, ein gutes Verhältnis zu den Kollegen zu haben. Also ich habe nicht versucht, durch irgendwelche, weiß ich, Traumaseibe in die Unterhose zu schmieren.
Wer hat das gemacht? Das ist doch jetzt kein Beispiel.
Das sage ich nicht. Das gab es tatsächlich.
Ach komm, das ist doch verjährt.
Nein, aber es war immer Konkurrenzkampf irgendwie mit offenem Visier und auch kollegial und so war es in der Phase auch. Also Sascha Elitsch kam eben aus Korea mit der großen Chance in Deutschland, jetzt spielen zu können. Jörg Budt hat auch die Chance gewittert. Wir waren uns relativ ähnlich von der Mentalität her. Wir haben super zusammengearbeitet.
Hansjörg Budt galt ja schon als einer der Torhüter, der auch sehr gut mit dem Fuß war. Dann natürlich die berühmten Strafstöße, die er ausgeführt hat. Wart ihr euch auf ein Torwartspiel ähnlich?
Also was ganz oft passiert jetzt so nach zehn Jahren, nachdem ich aufgehört habe, ich weiß nicht, ob das bei ihm auch so ist, ob er mit mir verwechselt wird. Aber die Leute, ich werde ganz oft auch darauf angeschworen, die haben so viel Elfmeter geschossen.
Du hast sie gehalten, du bist einer der besten Elfmeter-Parierer.
Ich habe sie gehalten, der Wutt hat sie geschossen. Ich habe sie, ich sage das immer näher, ich habe nur einen geschossen. Das war im Pokal gegen Bayer Leverkusen Amateure.
Genau, in der ersten Runde damals. Und als entscheidender Schütze.
Ja, erst gehalten und dann war ich so voller Adrenalin, habe gar nicht zu den anderen geguckt, habe den Ball genommen und reingehauen und dann war vorbei. Ja, genau. Also wir sind uns ähnlich. Er ist groß, ich bin groß. Auch so auf den ersten Blick aus 100 Meter Entfernung könnte man uns tatsächlich verwechseln. Wir sind beide auch eher unspektakuläre, sachliche Torhüter gewesen, die jetzt nicht so viel Schi-Schi gemacht haben. Klar waren wir uns ähnlich, aber er war jemand, der von unten, der jüngere Shootingstar, der nach oben wollte und hat die Chance einfach genutzt. Er ist auch sicherlich in eine Nische reingestoßen, wo die Stimmung mir gegenüber nicht so positiv war. Jeder, der jetzt gekommen wäre, den hätten sie mit offenen Armen empfangen. Er hat das total verdient. Wir haben nicht ein böses Wort miteinander gewechselt. Das war total okay. Für mich war der Zeitpunkt gekommen, zu gehen. Das war mir klar, das wusste ich. Deswegen war das für mich kein Problem, dass jemand anderes im Tor stand. Im Gegenteil, ich war erleichtert, dass er es in den Jahren danach so gut gemacht hat. Das wäre nicht schlimmer, als wenn mein Nachfolger sich die Bälle selber reinwirft. Dann hätte jeder gedacht, wie schlecht war der Vorgänger.
So habe ich da gar nicht drauf geguckt. Die zweite Frage, die ich dazu noch habe, war dein Abschied vom HSV nach elf Jahren. Wir sprechen über das Jahr 1998. Da bist du dann nach Freiburg gegangen. Am letzten Spiel, der KT HSV in Heimspiel, gegen den schon feststehenden Meister, er ist der FC Kaiserslautern. War das jemals angedacht, dass das für dich ein Abschiedsspiel sein könnte?
Nein, ich habe es ja auch gar nicht gemacht. Nein, die Situation war zum Ende mit Pagelsdorf ein bisschen gespannt, weil zwei, drei Wochen vorher beim Auswärtsspiel in Dortmund gab es ein paar Spieler, die abends zu lange noch nicht im Bett waren. Ich war mit dabei, wir saßen irgendwo bei einem auf dem Zimmer und haben uns unterhalten.
Unterhalten?
Tatsächlich weder Alkohol noch sonst irgendwas. Wir waren einfach ein bisschen doof, alle frustrierten, haben sich zusammengetan. Wir waren noch unten in der Hotelhalle, um halb zwölf. Das war sicherlich extrem dämlich. Am nächsten Morgen hat Pagelsdorf alle Feldspieler nach Hause geschickt. Mich hat er gedacht, ich brauche er vielleicht noch in dem Spiel. Die anderen, ich glaube, es waren zwei oder drei Jungs, mussten dann mit dem Zug nach Hause fahren. Ich bin dann halt noch da geblieben, weil Torwart braucht man vielleicht. Hätte es sein können, dass wieder ein Foto gemacht wird. Und dann war auch klar, dass ich da jetzt nicht irgendwie noch ein Abschiedsspiel kriege. War halt irgendwie, wie das so ist. Du bist beleidigt, dass du nicht spielst. Dann tun sich ein paar zusammen und dann kommen so komische Geschichten aus.
Gut, ich meine, es ist ja auch nicht immer Platz für Sentimentalitäten. Es ging ja auch irgendwie, auch in diesem letzten Spiel noch um irgendwas. So ist es ja immer. Aber jetzt beginnt dann deine Freiburger Zeit, auf die du schon eingegangen bist. Also Tottenheim hat sich dann im Sommer nicht mehr gemeldet. Wie kam es dann zum SC Freiburg?
Das kam dann so, es gab im alten Trainingsgelände am Ochsenzoll in Norderstedt gab es so einen Raum, wo sich Spieler nach dem Training immer getroffen haben und zusammengesessen haben, ein bisschen gequatscht haben. Und da war auch Andi Zeier dabei, der ja zum HSV kam. Und so zum Ende der Saison unterhält man sich so, was machst du? Und dann war klar, ich suche nach einem Verein. Und dann sagte Andi irgendwie so, wäre nicht Freiburg für dich eigentlich interessant? Und so sage ich, ja klar, warum nicht? Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob er danach bei Volker Finke angerufen hat, aber irgendwann meldet sich mein Berater, Wolfgang Vögel bei mir und sagte, du, ich habe hier mit Freiburg gesprochen und so, die sind interessiert, die suchen einen Torwart, steigen ja vielleicht noch auf. Also es war zu dem Zeitpunkt war es noch nicht klar, die waren halt auch im Aufstiegskampf. Und dann habe ich gesagt, ja, warum nicht? Also ich war ein Jahr vorher, war ich in Freiburg, weil ich eine Schulterverletzung hatte, die habe ich mir im Derby geholt gegen St. Pauli, allerdings nicht bei dem Spiel, sondern einem davor und hatte Schulterprobleme, bin zu Klümpa gefahren, habe die irgendwie tagelang behandeln lassen, hat auch nicht funktioniert und war dann halt ein paar Tage in Freiburg und habe so dieses ganze Drumherum da genossen, schöne Stadt, locker draußen gesessen im Café und so, es war alles toll und da habe ich schon einen guten Eindruck gehabt. Wir haben in Freiburg auch ein- zweimal gespielt und das war auch gut, also das Stadion war nett. Ich hatte einen total positiven Eindruck. Ja und dann sagte der Vögel, gut, Fynke, ruf dich mal an und dann sprecht ihr mal und dann haben wir telefoniert. Und ja, da habe ich gedacht, klar, warum nicht? Und haben uns dann verabredet an einem trainingsfreien Tag, Dienstag oder Mittwoch. Freiburg hat dann für mich einen Flug nach Basel organisiert. Volker Fynke hat mich dann am Flughafen abgeholt und dann war das echt...
Was für ein Auto fuhr Volker Fynke im Jahr 1998?
Das war ein Peugeot, wie man da unten sagt. Also das ist schon zehn Jahre alt und das konnte man daran erkennen. Volker Fynke hat offensichtlich eine Sammelleidenschaft. Der ist jedes Jahr zum Skifahren gefahren und hat dann diese in Frankreich... Nicht zum Skifahren, sondern in Frankreich hast du auch so eine Vignette. Und er hat da, ich glaube, von den letzten acht Jahren Dinge so übereinander oder so in einer Reihe an der Scheibe gehabt. Also da konntest du schon locker erkennen, wie alt das Auto ist. Aber fuhr gut und so.
Und dann erst mal Radio angemacht, Kassettenrekorder und schön die Timelife-Hits des Summer of Love, oder?
Nee, aber das war total lustig, weil er hat mich dann am Flughafen abgeholt und sagt, komm, wir fahren jetzt nach Basel. Weil die waren wirklich im Aufstiegskampf und er sagt, ich will jetzt nicht, dass uns in Freiburg irgendjemand sieht und das so ein bisschen dann Unruhe bringt. Wir fahren nach Basel. Da können wir in Ruhe quatschen. Und dann fahren wir in die Innenstadt, gehen in ein Restaurant, um was zu essen und kommen in den Laden rein. Und was passiert, steht einer da und sagt, Herr Golz, was machen Sie denn hier? Herr Finke, wollen Sie unseren Torwart wegholen? Zumindest ein Hamburger oder ein Sympathisant. Ich meine, HSV-Fans gibt es auf der ganzen Welt. Da kannst du hinkommen, wo du willst. Das ist echt unglaublich, wie groß die Fanbase ist. Das war schon extrem lustig.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen. Du hast dann später mal gesagt im Rückblick, in Freiburg habe ich eine andere Art und Weise kennengelernt, mit dem Fußball umzugehen. Dort wurde mehr reflektiert und miteinander geredet. Ich habe bald gemerkt, so geht es auch.
Ja, das fing schon damit an, dass wir zum Beispiel in der Vorbereitung auf so ein Bundesligaspiel zu Hause geschlafen haben. Als ich das das erste Mal gehört habe, habe ich gedacht, undenkbar, ich kann ja nicht zu Hause schlafen. Da stört mich doch alles, da werde ich abgelenkt, da kann ich nicht schlafen und was ist, wenn die Kinder im Nerven und so. Aber natürlich geht das, alles eine Frage der Einstellung. Und dann haben wir morgens trainiert, immer fünfeinhalb Stunden vor dem Wettkampf. So, kein Verein hat das gemacht. Wir haben trainiert.
Normalerweise macht man nur Anschwitzen, Essen, Mittagsruhe, Spaziergang.
Also in Freiburg war es in den ersten Jahren so, da wurde zum Beispiel am Tag vor dem Wettkampf gar nicht trainiert. Also wir spielen am Samstag, am Freitag frei. Da habe ich schon gedacht, ey, was macht ihr denn hier eigentlich so? Und dann Samstagmorgen trainieren vor dem Wettkampf fünfeinhalb Stunden. Das war halt so eine super Kompensation.
Also nicht fünfeinhalb Stunden trainieren, sondern quasi fünfeinhalb Stunden vor dem Wettkampf.
Genau. Du hast dann, meinetwegen am Mittwoch, Donnerstag noch ein bisschen Gas gegeben, hast dich am Freitag erholt und hast dann sozusagen Aktivierung am Samstag gemacht, fünfeinhalb Stunden vor dem Wettkampf, dann Nudeln gegessen und bist im Stadion geblieben. Also nichts irgendwie im Hotel gelangweilt. Das war nämlich das, was Fink ja auch gesagt hat. Ja, ich habe alle möglichen Trainer gefragt, alle Spieler von anderen Vereinen. Was macht ihr am Freitag im Hotel vor dem Spiel? Und keiner hat irgendwas Vernünftiges gesagt, keine Videoanalyse oder sowas. Wir haben alle gesagt, wir haben uns gelangweilt. Dann sagt er, das können wir auch zu Hause machen. Ja, und dann haben wir uns morgens getroffen, haben trainiert und haben dann gegessen, sind dann im Stadion geblieben. Dann hast du dich halt im Stadion noch eine Stunde gelangweilt. Aber das war einfach alles ein bisschen entspannter. Und wir haben auch gewonnen und haben gute Spiele gemacht. Also es funktionierte, das war relativ schnell klar. Und von der Sorte gibt es auch noch andere Beispiele.
Welche denn?
Ja, Kleinigkeiten auch. Wir haben dann so Schnelligkeitstests gemacht mit der Lichtschranke. Einfach Lichtschranke aufgebaut, durchgelaufen. Und jeder wollte sofort seine Ergebnisse sehen. War total spannend und du bist natürlich auch gelaufen, wie du sonst nicht laufen würdest wahrscheinlich. Das führte aber dazu. Man hat schon gemerkt, dass Volker Finke – den muss man ja auch immer mit Achim Saarstedt in einem Atemzug nennen, weil die beiden haben sich supergut ergänzt. Und Volker Finke wäre sicherlich ohne Achim Saarstedt auch nicht so erfolgreich in Freiburg gewesen. Also Achim Saarstedt auch als der große Denker und Strategie, der auch ganz viel Trainingsplanung gemacht hat und Trainingssteuerung und auch alle möglichen Spieler beobachtet hat. Der hat eigentlich auch nur im Auto gewohnt. Also wirklich ein extrem wichtiger Part. Und die waren auch die ersten, die eben so Schnelligkeitstraining oder auch dann eben die Messungen gemacht haben. Und dann hast du aber auch gemerkt, in Freiburg ist ja auch fast niemand zum Training gekommen, was Medien betrifft. Also wenn da mal einer kam, war eine große Aufregung. Und irgendwie war den beiden schon auch wichtig, dass Rest Deutschland auch davon erfährt, wie innovativ wir sind. Also wenn dann irgendwie… Ja, so ein bisschen schon. Also kann ich auch verstehen, weil irgendwie, ja, hier die kleinen Freiburger Studenten da und so, was machen die da? Und wenn dann irgendwie auf einmal hast du gesehen, hier Sat 1 hat seinen Kamerawagen da oder hat ausgepackt und so.
Dann kam die besondere Übung.
Dann kam Finke und sagt, Achim, Achim, bau mal die Lichtschranke auf. Wir machen heute die Schnelligkeitstest.
Aber war das damals tatsächlich so innovativ, im Jahr 1998?
Ja, doch. Also vom HSV kannte ich das nicht. Vielleicht haben es andere Vereine auch gemacht, aber die haben es halt dann nicht gemacht, wenn die Kameras kamen. Irgendwie, wenn es keiner gemerkt hat.
Und wie war das Torwartspiel für dich in Freiburg? War das auch anders als beim HSV?
Naja, das fing ja damit an, dass ich dann auf einmal einen Torwarttrainer hatte und mit dem auch individueller trainieren konnte. Und klar, ich war in der Hinsicht schon ein bisschen mehr gefordert, weil man natürlich auch versucht hat, den Ball laufen zu lassen. Also ich habe viel mehr Kontakte am Fuß gehabt, musste mich dann auch anpassen. Und bin der Meinung, dass ich mich da auch dann auch noch ein Stück mit 30 dann noch verbessert habe. Und ja, also es hieß ja nicht ohne Grund, glaube ich, die Breisgau-Brasilianer, die gibt es ja heute immer noch, obwohl die in der Form, das glaube ich nicht mehr so gespielt haben, aber wir haben echt eine gute Kicker gehabt, mit denen man das auch sehr gut spielen konnte.
Ja, ich habe das nochmal versucht im Nachhinein nachzuvollziehen. Und da gab es zum Beispiel einen Spielbericht aus einem UEFA Cup Spiel, da schrieb dann der Kicker, das war im Jahr 2001, das war dann die UEFA Cup Saison, ja, Freiburg tritt im bekannten 2-6-2 an. Und ich dachte mir, um Gottes Willen, 2-6-2? Und dann habe ich mir eben mal die Starterstellung angeguckt und ich meine, das ist ja erstmal nur eine Notation und wie das auf dem Feld ist, ist ja was anderes. Aber was damals Freiburg meiner Erinnerung nach von vielen Bundesligisten unterschieden hat, war, dass man eben zum einen Ballbesitzfußball spielen wollte, dass er auf kurzen Pässen basierte, dass auch das Passspiel kultiviert wurde, also durch viele Trainingsübungen. Davon hat ja auch Volker Finke viel erzählt, dass der Torhüter dadurch auch mit eingebunden war. Und vor allem aber, dass es viele Situationen gab, in denen sich unverhältnismäßig viele Spieler im Vergleich zu anderen Bundesligisten in der gegnerischen Hälfte befunden haben. Musstest du dann besonders häufig rauskommen, um zu retten? Musstest du das Torwartspiel vielleicht schon ähnlich interpretieren, wie später dann Manuel Neuer, der ja ganz oft so weit vor seinem Tor stand? Weil dazu konnte ich leider weniger finden.
Also es führte nicht dazu, dass wir sehr weit hoch oder sehr hoch standen. Ich kann mich erinnern, als ich kam, haben wir mit einer Viererkette gespielt. Und das wurde dann relativ schnell, nach ein, zwei Jahren, eine Dreierkette. Damit waren wir schon relativ innovativ. Also das war dann, ja, ich glaube, die meiste Zeit haben wir dann wirklich mit einer Dreierkette gespielt. Und ich weiß, Volker Finke hat die Aufstellung, also dann, was im Mittelfeld sich hat, da vier Leute sozusagen als Block hingestellt. Also wie so ein Würfel, da standen dann vier Namen und die haben aber alle Freiheiten gehabt.
Rotiert.
Dann haben rotiert, also da hat keiner auf der Position gespielt, wie es auf der Tafel stand. Und das war auch so ein bisschen das Prinzip von ihm, den Spielern einfach auch ganz viel Freiheiten zu lassen. Also er hat die Ordnung vorgegeben. Es hat sich aber ganz anders oder oft, zumindest was die Offensive betrifft, anders dargestellt. Defensiv waren wir schon einigermaßen geordnet. In der Offensive war es so ein bisschen das Chaos-Prinzip und hat natürlich dazu geführt, also wir haben dann eben so jemanden wie Alexander Jashvili, ein brillanter Techniker und Dribbler, der konnte da unheimlich gut seine Stärken einbringen auch. Und solche Leute gibt es heute fast gar nicht mehr. Also das 1 gegen 1 gegen ihn war sowas von undankbar, weil er halt mit seinem niedrigen Schwerpunkt und seiner Ballsicherheit die Leute verrückt gemacht hat. Hat leider nicht so viele Tore geschossen, viele vorbereitet, aber das war eine absolute Waffe für uns. Und dann eben Leute mit einer unheimlich großen Laufbereitschaft wie Tobias Willi, der auf der Außenbahn eigentlich von vorne bis hinten alles gespielt hat. Der hat die Flanke reingehauen und sie selber am liebsten noch verwertet, zumindest läuferisch wäre das möglich gewesen. War dann auch sofort wieder der Erste, der hinten war. Oder unser Subayah Bayer im Mittelfeld auch unheimlich guter Kreativspieler mit einer wahnsinnigen Laufbereitschaft. Adel Selimi, auch ein Stürmer, der gelaufen ist, wahrscheinlich 15 Kilometer. Wir haben eine unheimlich große Laufbereitschaft gehabt und die haben wir auch gebraucht, weil es eben hin und wieder etwas ungeordnet war. Aber das betraf eigentlich eher die Offensive. Aber das war eben auch unsere Stärke.
Und dann gehen wir in die Saison 98, 99 rein. Freiburg als Aufsteiger in die 1. Liga beginnt sensationell. In den ersten zehn Spielen nur eine Niederlage. Und vielleicht für dich das wichtigste Spiel der Saison. Das 0 zu 0 in Hamburg. Denn in der letzten Minute passiert was?
Das war in Freiburg. Ich muss dich leider korrigieren. Wenn ich sage, was so diese HSV-Geschichte betrifft, das Derby als Worst Case war das erste Heimspiel mit dem SC gegen den HSV. In Freiburg gegen den HSV. In der 90. Minute, 11 Meter für den HSV. Jörg Budt schießt einen 11 Meter und alle, die er vorher geschossen hat, hat er verwandelt. Den ersten, den er nicht verwandelt hat, war gegen mich in der letzten Minute. Punkt gerettet. Ich glaube, die Leute stehen heute noch auf den Bänden und jubeln. Das war unglaublich. Das war ein Gefühl, das ich in 21 Jahren nicht so oft erlebt habe. Ich glaube, von der Intensität, das hat tatsächlich fast ein paar Tage angedauert.
Aber warum war dir das so wichtig, wenn du gleichzeitig sagst, ihr hättet einen so fairen Konkurrenzkampf geführt, wo du sagst, es wäre auch nie zu einem schlechten Wort oder so weiter gekommen? Also klar Ehrgeiz, verstehe ich. Aber ich dachte, das wäre so eine Anekdote für vielen. Aber du hebst es jetzt ja doch auf dem Podest in deiner Karriere.
Das hat mit Jörg Bött überhaupt nichts zu tun. Also das war eher der Situation, mir ein großes Bedürfnis oder noch mal dokumentieren zu können. Guck mal, Fußball Hamburg.
Ich habe es noch drauf.
Ich kann es, genau, ich kann es noch. Also Null Schadenfreude oder Hämme oder sonst irgendwie. Hier, du hast einen Elfmeter verschossen. Sondern mir ging es einfach darum, das nochmal zeigen zu können. Es gab dann auch nochmal ein Spiel, was auch mit diesem Derby zu tun hatte. Das war nämlich der erste Auftritt zwar im Trikot vom SC gegen St. Pauli in Hamburg. Da haben wir auch 1-0 gewonnen. Also 1-0 gewonnen, zu Null gespielt und eigentlich auch fast das Spiel meines Lebens gemacht. Damit konnte ich dann sozusagen dieses Worst-Case-Szenario für mich abhaken. Das war dann zwar in der zweiten Liga, glaube ich.
Genau, das war nicht in der ersten Liga Saison.
Ich denke auch, das war in der zweiten Liga. Genau, ich habe mich nämlich beim ersten Spiel in Hamburg gegen St. Pauli verletzt. Das hat dann so ein Ende genommen. Ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, wie Holger Stanislavski, der nämlich bei dem Derby in der ersten Liga auch mit dabei war, während des Spiels dann aber eine Ecke für St. Pauli stand da und sagte, was ist mit dir los? Du bist hier voll im Tunnel und ich glaube, da ist noch irgendwas gut zu machen.
Aber das heißt, du hast es auch gebraucht, um quasi diese lange Zeit in Hamburg so einen Akten zu legen. Weißt du denn dann noch, was genau ein Jahr später passiert ist, nachdem du diesen Elfmeter gehalten hast gegen Hans-Jörg Budt? Gab es die Retour-Kutsche? Da hat er dann beim 2-0-Sieg des HSV getroffen.
Das stimmt.
Aber da war ja schon alles für den Akten gelegt. Es gab noch ein anderes sehr interessantes Spiel in dieser Erstligasaison, das SC. Und zwar, du warst dabei beim Abgrundspiel, würde ich es jetzt nennen, des ersten FC Nürnberg. Ihr habt in Nürnberg gespielt und der Club hat damals nach allem, was man hört, das kannst du jetzt widerlegen, wenn es zu widerlegen ist, schon vor dem Spiel euch auf die Klassenerhaltsfeier eingeladen durch Spiele. Und am Ende sind sie abgestiegen durch ein 1 zu 2. Und da gab es diese Szene mit Frank Baumann kurz vor Schluss, wo immer noch Clubfans – ich komme ja aus dem Frankenland, habe dann später fünf Jahre in Freiburg studiert. Also ich habe zu beiden Parteien ein emotionales... Klubfans kriegen da heutzutage noch eine Halsschlagader von der Breite der A9, wenn sie über dieses Haus von Frank Baumann reden. Kannst du mich mal reinholen, was ist da passiert an diesem 34. Spieltag und war euch vor allem auf dem Platz auch immer bewusst, worum es da jetzt geht? Frankfurt hat ein Tor nach dem anderen geschossen und dadurch die wildesten Konstellationen herbeigeführt, den Abstiegskampf und am letzten Ende hat es dann denjenigen getroffen mit dem Klub, der am wenigsten wahrscheinlich als Absteiger herausgehen würde aus diesem Spieltag.
Ja, also wir sind nach Nürnberg gefahren und in dem Bewusstsein, wir dürfen das Spiel nicht verlieren. Und das war tatsächlich so, wir kommen nach Nürnberg und die Tabellenkonstellation war ja echt abgefahren, da waren viele Vereine relativ eng beieinander und die Nürnberger, relativ locker, haben gesagt, hier nach dem Spiel und so sitzen wir zusammen, wenn ihr wollt, könnt ihr noch ein bisschen bleiben und trinken wir noch ein Bier zusammen und so, alles klar. Und ja, dann ist das Spiel gut verlaufen für uns, wir haben schnell geführt und Mitte der zweiten Halbzeit hast du gemerkt, wie die Stimmung im Stadion kippt. Also es stand ja die ganze Zeit 2-1 und die Nürnberger…
Also 2-0 stand es ja, in der 85. haben sie dann den Anschlusstreffer.
Und naja, in der zweiten Halbzeit waren die Nürnberger ja noch safe und so haben sie auch gespielt. Also eher kontrolliert, so nach dem Motto, wir kriegen jetzt nicht das dritte, wir schmeißen nicht alles um jeden Preis nach vorne und die Ergebnisse wurden nicht eingeblendet auf der Anzeigetafel, also man wusste nicht so genau, was passiert jetzt. Du hast aber anhand der Zuschauer gemerkt, irgendwas stimmt da nicht so richtig, die haben dann irgendwie Radio gehört scheinbar oder also Handys gab es ja in der Form glaube ich noch nicht, Smartphones.
Aber das heißt, ihr wusstet auch keine Zwischenstände, ich meine, ihr wusstet natürlich, wenn ihr das gewinnt, dann seid ihr durch, das war sicher, das heißt, es war jetzt für euch nicht wichtig, jeden Zwischenstand zu kennen, ich glaube, da war ja Hanzo Rostock dann auch noch in Bochum ja auch noch wichtig mit Drömm beteiligt, aber das heißt, ihr als Spieler wusstet jetzt auch nicht genau.
Ne, ne, also wir wussten nur und das war auch unser Ziel, also wir müssen das verteidigen oder wir dürfen nicht verlieren, so haben wir auch gespielt. Also wir sind ja, wir sind relativ offensiv in das Spiel reingegangen, sagen wir mal so. Also wir haben schon versucht nach vorne zu spielen und das hat ja auch gut funktioniert. Das war jetzt keine reine Abwehrschlacht und wir haben dann auch, das lag vielleicht daran, dass die Nürnberger das lange unterschätzt haben, haben das Spiel dann auch lange Zeit wirklich kontrolliert und hatten mehr Ballbesitz. Also das war so, es sah von außen aus wie, okay, jetzt bringen wir das beide so zu Ende und dann hast du gemerkt, dann wurden auch die Anweisungen von der Nürnberger Bank ein bisschen hektischer und so diese ganze Unruhe hast du gemerkt, das kriegt man mit. Weil die Zuschauer dann, das merkst du ja, wenn dann Tausende irgendwie so machen, weil sie eben im Radio gerade gehört haben, dass Frankfurt das 3-1 oder 4-1 gemacht hat und dann wurde es irgendwann dramatisch und dann kam diese Situation, ich glaube, nach einer Ecke, ein Schuss aus dem Rückraum von Marek Nickel, Ball geht gegen den Pfosten, ich war, glaube ich, noch irgendwie so halb dran, springt mir gegen den Rücken und springt dann im 5-Meter-Raum, der wirklich zu dem Zeitpunkt nicht gut war, also der war ein bisschen holprig, der Ball hoppelte, ich habe so gedacht, den will ich auch nicht unbedingt versuchen, den kann man machen, aber es ist einer von den Bällen, der eher undankbar ist und dann, ja, habe ich nur irgendwie gesehen, ach ja, jetzt versuche ich noch irgendwie da an den Ball zu kommen und er hat ihn, Frank Baumann hat ihn ja nicht richtig getroffen, Ich hatte keine Chance, ich hab den dann gehalten. Im Nachhinein hätte dann ja ein Tor, wenn Baumann den Ball reingeschossen hätte und Nürnberg hätte noch ein Tor mehr geschossen, dann hätten wir, glaube ich, Relegation gespielt.
Ihr werdet runtergegangen. Ich glaube, es gab sogar auch noch die Konstellation, dass, wenn der reingegangen wäre, hätte auch noch ein Tor von Eintracht Frankfurt gereicht.
Das meine ich. Dann wären wir weg gewesen. Diese Dramatik hat man natürlich in dem Moment nicht gemerkt oder war mir nicht so bewusst. Ich habe nur so gedacht während des Spiels, wenn wir das Spiel gewinnen, kann ja sowieso nichts passieren.
Was passiert dann in so einem Spiel nach dem Abpfiff? Ich habe dann im Nachhinein gelesen, dass ihr erst im Mannschaftskreis danach erfahren habt, da hat einer der Co-Trainer gesagt, wenn der reingegangen wäre und Frankfurt hätte noch eins gemacht, dann wären wir runtergegangen. Du hast dann später gesagt, dass dir das so flau im Magen geworden ist, dass du erst mal den Jubelkreis verlassen hast und dich gar nicht mehr so wirklich freuen könntest, weil es so knapp war.
Ja, das war tatsächlich so. Wir sind dann in der Kabine gewesen und waren noch mindestens zwei Stunden im Stadion und haben irgendwie da gefeiert und haben dann aber auch die Nürnberger gesehen und das war...
Kann man denn da feiern? Also zwei Stunden, da ist das Stadion ja auch leer, da sind da dann nur noch ein paar arme Nürnberger Würstel.
Ja, ja klar. Wir sind natürlich erstmal draußen bei den Fans gewesen und haben mit denen gefeiert und dann vergeht schon die Zeit. Dann kam irgendjemand und hat ein bisschen Bier organisiert und sitzt so in der Kabine und singst und lachst und so und gleichzeitig merkst du dann, aber wenn du da rausgehst, oh hier ist irgendwie was ganz Dramatisches passiert.
Ich bin gespannt, ob du die Geschichte mit dem Juggelkreis noch mal der Sportshow erzählen darfst am 34. Spieltag.
Lustigerweise spielt am 34. Spieltag auch der SC gegen Nürnberg, zwar in Freiburg und das ist aber auch wiederum eine schöne Geschichte, weil das auch ein Moment ist, wieder eine Gelegenheit ist, nach Freiburg zu fahren. Denn es gibt seit einem Jahr die neu formierte Traditionsmannschaft vom SC Freiburg, die sich so ein paar Mal im Jahr trifft und anlässlich dieser Begebenheit spielen wir einen Tag vor dem Bundesligaspiel mit der Traditionsmannschaft gegen die Nürnberger. Ich bin gespannt, ob wir das dann noch mal nachstellen.
Aber bist du da dann im Tor? Weil ich habe mal gelesen, dass du dich bei Benefitspielen nicht mehr ins Tor stellst, aus gesundheitlichen Gründen.
Ja und nein. Also vor einem Jahr war das gleiche schon mal, da haben wir gegen Augsburg gespielt, auch mit dem Sportclub. Und da habe ich eine Halbzeit im Tor gespielt und eine zweite Halbzeit dann draußen. Weil ja, also in der Halle finde ich, macht es mehr Spaß, da hast du mehr Aktion als Torwart und so. Und da kannst du auch unheimlich gut mit Stellungsspiel glänzen, weil das Tor ist nicht so groß und dann stehst du da und das sieht immer noch gut aus. Auf dem Feld fehlt ja natürlich schon ein bisschen die Schnelligkeit und ich mag mich mit meinen 100 Kilo auch nicht mehr so viel auf den Boden schmeißen. Von daher spiele ich auch gerne mal im Feld, aber da war es so, da musste ich wirklich 45 Minuten im Feld spielen und habe danach zwei Wochen echt Schmerzen gehabt. Deswegen muss ich noch mal darüber nachdenken, ob ich das so handhaben könnte oder sollte. Ich spiele halt wirklich nicht mehr so oft Fußball oder stehe nicht so oft im Tor, weil es mich dann echt ein paar Tage Schmerzen kostet.
Ja, da würde ich dann gerne zum Ende des Gesprächs noch mal kurz mit dir drüber sprechen, was der Leistungssport mit deinem Körper gemacht hat. Jetzt lass mal kurz noch über die Freiburger Zeit ein bisschen drüber huschen. Besonders heraus sticht die Saison 2001. Da kamen dann Sebastian Kehle, Vladimir Bud Carmen, Sumayya Kolibali. Es gab einen verrückten Saisonverlauf in der Hinserie, eine Phase von sieben Spielen mit sechs Niederlagen und einem Sieg bei einem Torverhältnis von 4 zu 15. Und dann verliert der SC zwischen November und Saisonende nur noch drei Mal, landet in der Rückrundetabelle auf dem zweiten Platz hinter dem Bayern und spielt auf einmal UEFA Cup. Und du hast einen zu Null Rekord aufgestellt mit fünf Spielen in Folge zu Null.
Ja, das war eine tolle Saison. Das war wirklich unglaublich. Und ich kann mich noch daran erinnern, in der Winterpause hatten wir eine fürchterliche Vorbereitung. Wir waren irgendwie wie jedes Jahr in Portugal. Das war so unser Stammdomizil. Und da hat es die ganze Zeit nur geregnet. Wir konnten nicht auf dem Platz. Wir haben eigentlich fast die ganze Zeit nur so Fußballtennis in der Halle gespielt.
Hört sich eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht an. Aber unvorbereitungstechnisch hat nicht so gut.
Ja, genau. Also das war eigentlich fast nicht möglich, sich vernünftig vorzubereiten auf die Rückrunde. Und dann hatte das so eine Eigendynamik. Wir sind dann gut in die Rückrunde gestartet. Und irgendwann dann kam der Punkt, wo du dann gemerkt hast, okay, jetzt ist auch rechnerisch nichts mehr möglich. Und das hat uns dann nochmal einen Riesenschub gegeben.
Also nach unten.
Genau, also der Klassenhalt war dann relativ schnell gesichert. Und dann haben wir, glaube ich, die letzten Spiele auch irgendwie gefühlt alle gewonnen. Und auch Spiele, wo du dann normalerweise irgendwie denkst, du hast keine Chance, gewinnst zu 1-0 zu Hause gegen Hertha. Und die spielen die ganze Zeit auf dein Tor, schießt einmal vorne aufs Tor und gewinnst ein Spiel. Also da hat alles gepasst. Und ich meine, da waren auch echt gute Kicker. Also Wladimir Budt, auch ein Riesenfußballer gewesen, der sich dann so auf Strecke in Freiburg nicht durchgesetzt hat, aber da eine unheimlich gute Phase hatte. Sebastian Kehl am Anfang seiner Karriere, der dann ja auch danach wechselte. Und Kuli Bali, auch ein Riesenkicker mit einem Wahnsinnsschuss, später auch in Gladbach gelandet. Also vom Talent her auch eine unheimlich gute Mannschaft.
Das leitet jetzt dann quasi schon so nahtlos über auch der Abschied von Sebastian Kehl in die Saison 2001, 2002, wobei der Wechsel von Sebastian Kehl damals im Winter erfolgt ist. Es war damals ein großes Hin und Her. Es gab einen mündlichen Vorvertrag mit dem Bayern. Die hatten ihn schon 1, 5 Millionen Mark überwiesen. Er hat das dann mit Zins des Zinses zurück überwiesen. Und dann musste das vom DFB damals geklärt werden. Das hatte ich auch alles schon wieder vergessen, dass dann Sebastian Kehl zu Dortmund wechseln durfte und der FC Bayern nicht mehr so böse auf ihn war. Also verziehen haben sie es ihm sicherlich nie, so wie man die Bayern kennt. Aber wir wollen über den SC Freiburg reden. Und das war ja dann die UEFA Cup-Saison 2001, 2002. Der Start in der Bundesliga war völlig okay. Im UEFA Cup hat man in der ersten Runde gegen den MSK Puchow in der Slowakei gespielt, auswärts 0-0, zu Hause dann 2-1 gewonnen, aber schon relativ dramatisch mit einem verschossenen Elfmeter und dem entscheidenden Treffer in der 88. Minute. Du nix wissend. Geht der Puls noch mal nachträglich hoch.
Ich glaube sogar, dass Ibrahim Tanko das Tor geschossen hat.
Ibrahim Tanko, genau, hat in der 88. Minute das Tor gemacht. Und dann ging es weiter gegen St. Gallen, zu Hause, durch ein Tor in der 93. Minute verloren. Das war sehr unglücklich. Da hatte, meiner Erinnerung nach, auch der SC einige Chancen. Dann aber auswärts 4-1 gewonnen, sicher weitergekommen gegen St. Gallen. Ich bin mir gerade gar nicht sicher, aber könnte sein, dass Marcel Koller da Trainer war von St. Gallen. Genau, so ist es. Und jetzt kommt der Climax, auf den ich die ganze Zeit hinleite, dass die dritte Runde im UEFA Cup gegen Feyenoord, die dann später den Pokal gewinnen sollten, tatsächlich gegen Borussia Dortmund in dieser Saison. Ich hole mich mal rein in das Rückspiel. Das Hinspiel ging relativ unglücklich verloren durch ein spätes Tor. Spätes 1-0. Das findet man tatsächlich auch noch mit niederländischen Kommentaren in großen Auszügen bei YouTube. Da hat der SC vor allem in der zweiten Halbzeit ein gutes Spiel gemacht. Da war Feyenoord nicht so stark. Und dann jetzt das Rückspiel. Wir haben das 1-0 durch Kehl. Dadurch wird das Hinspiel egalisiert. Wir haben das 2-0 durch Kobjasz Willi, Vfm. Und dann kommt ein Freistoß von Van Heudonck, der heute noch in YouTube-Kommentaren von niederländischen Fans gefeiert wird. Kann ich dir jetzt berichten?
Ja, das hat mir letztens auch ein holländischer Fan sogar irgendwie geschickt. Das stimmt, das hat sich jetzt auch gejährt. Ich würde sagen, das war ein Jahrhundert-Freistoß von einer Außenlinie fast. Natürlich würde ich sagen, als Torwart darf der nicht reingehen. Der war wirklich sensationell geschossen und trotzdem muss man ihn vielleicht halten.
Aber du standest ja auf der Linie, du bist ja nicht mal weit rausgegangen. Also im Normalfall wäre das eine Flanke geworden in den Sechzehner und du hättest rauskommen müssen aus deinem Tor oder halt auf der Linie parieren. Aber du standest ja eigentlich auch so…
Das weiß ich jetzt gar nicht genau, wo ich stand.
Aber du standst eigentlich ganz gut, also einen Meter vor der Torlinie. Also wobei ich jetzt auch nicht dafür bekannt bin, dass ich der Torwart Spezialist bin.
Ja, aber das spricht ja dafür, dass ich sage, den muss man wahrscheinlich halten. Trotzdem war das ein sensationeller Freistuss. Das war auch seine Spezialität. Also von heute an ein Riesen-Kicker gewesen. Ich habe mit dem HSV gegen ihn mal gespielt, als er noch bei Celtic Glasgow war. Und ja, das war natürlich extrem ärgerlich. Das war das 2-1. Später machen sie, glaube ich, noch das 2-2.
Das war ja noch das viel ärgerliche. Das war in der 88. Minute. Daran konnte ich mich vorher noch erinnern. Den Freistuss hatte ich ausgeblendet. Aber ich wusste noch, dass der SC damals sich quasi das Tor selber reingelegt hat, weil es nämlich Missverständnis gab innerhalb des 16ers und sich zwei SC-Spieler nicht einig waren, wer den Ball raushaut. Und dann hat ihn sich einfach Ono genommen. Ne, Leonardo war es. Ono hat ihn dann, glaube ich, rübergepasst und dann haben sie aus kurzer Distanz getroffen. Also es war so ein völlig irres Spiel.
Ja, also wir hätten noch eine Chance gehabt. Klar, wenn wir 3-1, wenn wir noch ein Tor nachgelegt hätten, wären wir ja weiter gekommen.
Und wie ist das jetzt? In der Rückschau ist es ja klar, wie man das bewertet. Das war dann insgesamt, also dieser Teil der Saison war sensationell und du hast leuchtende Augen bekommen, als ich von der ersten Runde schon erzählte. Da dachte ich mir, mein Gott, jetzt werden wir gemeinsam schwelgen. Aber wie war das damals, als SC Freiburg gegen Fair North Rotterdam so unglücklich auszuscheiden? Du hast später auch viel über das Freiburger Publikum zum Beispiel gesprochen. Du hast gesagt, dass das ein sehr, ich glaube, das steht sogar auf deiner Homepage, dass es ein sehr fachkundiges und faires Publikum wäre und dass ich das auch häufig getragen hätte. Wie war das jetzt zum Beispiel in diesem Moment?
Ja, die waren natürlich enttäuscht, ohne Frage. Ich weiß es ehrlich gesagt nicht mehr so ganz genau. Also es war schade, Leute haben sich geärgert, aber von jetzt extrem negativen Ausschlägen kann ich jetzt nichts berichten.
Ich hänge mich auch deswegen so ein bisschen an diesem Spiel auf, weil die Saison ja noch weiter ging. Am Ende der Hinrunde steht der SC auf Platz 12, hat 18 Punkte. Und am Ende der Saison steigt der SC Freiburg auf Platz 16 liegend ab. Wie viel hatte das denn mit dem Wechsel von Sebastian Kehl im Winter zu tun? Oder woran würdest du es festmachen, dass die Saison so gekippt ist, und zwar nicht wegen der Dreifachbelastung, weil in dem Moment, in dem es die Dreifachbelastung mit DFW-Pokal und UEFA Cup noch gab, alles gut lief und die Rückrunde war?
Sicherlich hat das eine Rolle gespielt, dass Sebastian Kehl nicht mehr da war, der eigentlich schon ein richtig guter Spieler war für uns, ein wichtiger Spieler. Gerade auf der strategisch wichtigen Position im Zentrum, weil er viele Sachen gelöst hat, nach vorne und auch nach hinten. Ich kann mich nur daran erinnern, es war dann in der Rückrunde so, wir haben ein paar Heimspiele gehabt, diese K.o.-Spiele, wo sich so eine Saison entscheidet. Wir haben dann verloren gegen Mainz zum Beispiel, unglücklich. Wir haben in einem Spiel auch mal 2-0 geführt und dann auch. Also es gab so die Spiele, die du dann gewinnen musst. Die haben wir alle verloren und sind dann echt nicht mehr aus dem Quark gekommen.
Und so ging es dann runter in die zweite Liga. Das war eine zweite Liga im Jahr 2002-2003. Da wird jetzt so manche Hörerinnen und manche Hörerinnen Erinnerung schweigen. Da waren Mannschaften dabei wie Alemannia Aachen, Eintracht Trier, Wackerburghausen, der VfB Lübeck, der LRA, Rot-Weiß Oberhausen, der SSV Reutlingen und Waldhof Mannheim. War das die beste zweite Liga aller Zeiten? Nee, sag mal mal, was war das für eine zweite Liga? Wie war das für dich? War ja auch zum ersten Mal in deiner Karriere, zweite Liga zu spielen in so einem Teilnehmerumfeld. Was war denn das für eine zweite Liga?
Jetzt kommt bei mir langsam noch ein bisschen die Erinnerung, was mir eben fehlte. Also diese Zweitligasaison begann für mich, ich kam aus einer Verletzung. Ich hatte mich nämlich beim Spiel gegen St. Pauli in Hamburg verletzt. Bei dem Spiel hatte sich auch Ibrahim Tanko, glaube ich, einen Kreuzbandriss geholt.
Genau, Verletzungen kamen auch noch.
Ab der Ramdane fiel in dem Spiel auch aus mit einer Innenbahnverletzung, glaube ich, und dann gab es, glaube ich, sogar noch eine rote Karte. Also es gab dann – und das war, glaube ich, im März, oder irgendwie so?
Genau, das war der 26. Spieltag. Danach konntest du kein Spiel mehr machen und der SC hat dann bis auf zwei Spiele alles verloren.
Ja, genau. Das war mir jetzt vorher gar nicht so bewusst. Das war eher dann der größere oder der wichtigere Grund, dass wir einfach auch nicht mehr nachlegen konnten personell und dann abgestiegen sind. Und ich dann von dort an wurde operiert, hatte einen Sehenabriss am Oberschenkel auf der Rückseite, was dann auch fixiert werden musste mit einem Titanstift in der Hüfte. Also das war echt bis zu dem Zeitpunkt die größte Verletzung, die ich hatte. Und bin dann echt so eine Punktlandung fit geworden zum ersten Spiel in der zweiten Bundesliga gegen Alemannia Aachen, da haben wir glaube ich 1-0 gewonnen. Und da habe ich schon gedacht, boah, das ist ja aber eine andere Welt hier.
Woran hast du das gemerkt?
Na ja, natürlich weniger Zuschauer, obwohl das auf dem Tivoli da noch trotzdem ganz stimmungsvoll war. Anderer Fußball einfach. Wobei wir an dem Tag echt Probleme hatten. Das war eigentlich auch fast so eine Abwehrschlacht. Wir haben glücklich 1-0 gewonnen. Aber ja, ich meine, das war eine Erfahrung. Zweite Liga kannte ich zu dem Zeitpunkt noch nicht so. Ich bin eigentlich auch, obwohl natürlich jeder am liebsten in der ersten Liga spielen will und man nicht absteigen möchte, aber das war auch ein Jahr, was auch Spaß gemacht hat und auch eine wichtige Erfahrung war. Und ich interessiere mich heute noch für Zweitliga-Fußball, weil es auch alles eine Spur weniger überdreht ist. Auch wenn ich heute Erstliga-Fußball gucke, gibt es ganz viele Situationen, wo ich denke, macht nicht so viel Theater draus. Lamentieren, Schwalben und so weiter und so fort. Das ist alles einen Tick zu überdreht. Das finde ich in der zweiten Liga noch sehr viel angenehmer.
Und wie war das als Erstliga-Absteiger dann eben da zu solchen Standorten, wie eben nach Oberhausen, nach Reutlingen, nach Mannheim zu fahren? Das sind ja jetzt nur die Vereine, die ich genannt habe, weil sie jetzt nicht mehr in der zweiten Liga sind und man sich da so ein bisschen zurück versetzt fühlt. Die Zeitsweine damals auch. Also Eintracht Frankfurt ist mit abgestiegen damals. Aber es gab ja auch noch die Klassiker eben. St. Pauli hast du ja schon genannt. Gegen Mainz habt ihr gespielt, gegen Duisburg, gegen Karlsruhe. Der erste FC Köln war damals in der zweiten Liga, Kräuter-Fürth. Wie war das da so als SC aus der ersten Liga, der ja auch noch UEFA Cup gespielt hat gegen Feyenoord anzutreten?
Ja, wir waren auf einmal der Favorit. Das war was ganz Neues für uns. Also in jedem Spiel waren wir der große Sportclub. Wir waren die Bayern der zweiten Liga, obwohl das jetzt nicht unbedingt vergleichbar ist. Aber klar, das haben wir aber relativ, ich fand, ganz gut gelöst.
Ihr hattet die beste Abwehr der Liga am Ende. Und seid souverän aufgestiegen am 32. Spieltag. Weißt du noch, wo und wie? Na klar, weißt du noch.
Ja, in Reutlingen. Ne, ne. Du hast ihm das überhaupt nie angemerkt. Er war immer total super konzentriert. Und so diesen ganzen Kampf, den er über Jahre mit sich selbst ausgetragen hat, er war halt ruhig. Aber da wäre ich nie im Leben drauf gekommen.
Würdest du sagen, dass da bei Torhütern noch mal mehr abläuft in ihrem Inneren als bei Feldspielern, die ja nicht so häufig auf einzelne Fehler reduziert werden, also deren Spiele nicht auf einzelne Fehler reduziert werden. Aber bei Torhütern ist es ja so, dass hier zum Beispiel so ein Max-Ost-Sitz und noch mal irgendwie zehn Jahre später über das Derby gegen St. Pauli sprechen möchte, weil du da einen schlechten Pass gespielt hast.
Ja, wobei – und dafür bin ich natürlich zu wenig Mediziner oder überhaupt nicht – Depression ist halt auch einfach eine Krankheit. Das kann sicherlich beeinflusst werden durch irgendwelche Ergebnisse oder Erlebnisse. Aber du hast natürlich als Torwart eine andere Verantwortung und jeder Fehler führt in der Regel zu irgendwelchen Toren oder Negativerlebnissen. Die Psyche eines Torwartes muss schon besonders resistent sein.
Genau, das wollte ich damit definitiv nicht sagen. Depression ist eine Krankheit, das ist was Biochemisches. Das kann auch sehr gut behandelt werden. Ich habe da nur viel darüber nachgedacht, weil Torhüter auch häufig so Typen sind. Wir haben über Uli Stein gesprochen, Oli Kahn hast du vorhin erwähnt, Hans-Jörg Budt, jemand, der dir eher ähnlich ist. Und jetzt beendest du ja deine Karriere in der Phase, in der Fußballdeutschland darüber diskutiert hat erst, wer soll im Tor stehen beim Sommermärchen, Jens Lehmann oder Oliver Kahn. Endergebnis kennen wir und dann ja jetzt dann genau die Phase, wo jetzt dann so eine neue Generation einzugeht. Also Robert Enkel noch als Vertreter einer Hybrid-Generation, würde ich es nennen, René Adler, Manuel Neuer waren dann die neueren Themen, Timo Hildebrandt kam auf, Sven Ulrich hat dann seine ersten Spiele für Stuttgart gemacht, also wir bewegen uns dann in die aktuelle Zeit hinein. Deswegen habe ich, so war die Frage gedacht. Jetzt müssen wir, auch wenn es schwerfällt, nach diesem schönen Gespräch jetzt diese 21 Jahre Profifußball für dich beenden und mich würde interessieren, wenn du zurückblickst, wenn du mit dem 19-jährigen Richard Golz sprechen könntest vor seinem ersten Bundesliga-Spiel. Was würdest du ihm sagen?
Also ich habe ja auch eine Zeit lang als Torwarttrainer gearbeitet im Anschluss an meine Karriere und ich habe eigentlich in Vorbereitungen von Spielen oder auch wenn ein junger Torwart sein erstes Spiel im Herrnbereich gemacht hat oder so. Natürlich musst du ja dann oder sprichst du mit den Jungs und versuchst denen was mit auf den Weg zu geben. Und mein Ansatz war eigentlich immer den Fokus möglichst oder den Rahmen möglichst klein zu halten. Also das Wichtige im Fußball ist im Grunde nur der nächste Ball und das kam glaube ich in der Öffnung.
Genau, das habe ich im Intro.
Und wenn dir das gelingt und das ist glaube ich die große Stärke von den großen Fußballern auch wirklich alles auszublenden und sich nur auf die nächste Aktion zu konzentrieren und das schaffst du nicht immer, weil ganz oft hast du natürlich auch Gelegenheit im Vorfeld eines Spiels zu überlegen, was kann alles passieren. Aber eben das sind die Typen, die das nicht machen, das sind die Guten, die Superguten, die das wirklich komplett ausblenden können in Situationen im Spiel oder drum herum und das ist das Allerwichtigste im Fußball, weil Talent und Fähigkeiten haben so viele andere auch und dann gehört natürlich auch ein bisschen Mentalität dazu, die richtigen Dinge zu trainieren, an deinen Stärken zu arbeiten, aber auch die Schwächen zu.
21 Jahre Bundesliga, von 1987 8000 Zuschauer gegen Wattenscheid bis eben dann ins Jahr 2008, auch wenn dir kein Bundesliga-Auftritt mehr vergönnt war. Die Liga hat sich so krass verändert, hat eine solche gesellschaftliche Bedeutung eingenommen. Was würdest du dir denn wünschen, wie sich die Bundesliga jetzt weiterentwickelt? Hat sie vielleicht auch an dem einen oder anderen Punkt einen Weg eingeschlagen, wo du sagst, das finde ich gar nicht so gut?
Also was ich gut finde, ist jetzt zum Beispiel im Zuge dieser ganzen Digitalisierung, dass man ganz viele interessante Daten bekommt. Also man muss natürlich gucken, dass man nicht alle Daten verwendet, weil nicht alle Daten sind interessant.
Ich sehe gerade schon ein Tribünengespräch, Teil 4. Das finde ich sehr interessant.
Genau, ich habe zwei Jahre für einen Start-up in Berlin gearbeitet, die sich mit dem Thema Digitalisierung beschäftigen. Tracking und Packing und so diese ganzen Sachen, Spielanalyse, Leistungsdiagnostik, das ist ja total spannend. Man muss nur eben aufpassen, dass man die richtigen Daten verwendet und nicht Äpfel mit Birnen vergleicht. Aber das finde ich total spannend, auch wenn man jetzt sieht, was so an Innovationen auf dem Markt sind. Die DFL treibt das ja auch wunderbar voran. Auch Analyse, Tools und so. Also das finde ich schon klasse, wenn man das dem Zuschauer so beibringt, dass er das auch wirklich gut findet und sich nicht langweilt und damit Daten erschlagen wird.
Glaubst du, es ist realistisch, dass sich Fußballzuschauer dafür mal begeistern werden für eine Analyse? Über die Analyse des Instagram-Posts?
Also um nochmal hier auf meine Tätigkeit für diese Start-up zu kommen. Der Gedanke war eigentlich so ein Score zu entwickeln, ähnlich wie bei FIFA. Und das ist ja finde ich ganz cool. Messi ist eine 99, ich bin eine 45 und du schaffst es eine Leistung eines Spielers wirklich so objektiv darzustellen. Also das interessante ist ja natürlich, das so zu programmieren, dass zum Beispiel, wie gewichtigst du einen Fehlpass in der 88. Minute, der zum Punktverlust führt? Dieser eine Pass, der vielleicht in deiner Statistik so marginal ist, als Fehlpass wird der zwar gewertet, aber der entscheidet das Spiel. Und das so zu bewerten, dass du dann anhand deines Scores sehen kannst, wie ist dein Impact auf dieses ganze Spiel, finde ich so was von spannend. Wenn das jemand schafft, dann bist du das neue Apple oder Microsoft.
Da arbeiten gerade viele dran. Okay, also Datentechnologisierung findest du gut. Gibt es was, wo du sagst, da hat sich die Liga hinentwickelt, wo du nicht ganz zufrieden damit bist?
Ja, ich finde natürlich, das, was auf dem Spielfeld passiert, ist teilweise jetzt echt absurd und albern. Ich rede da jetzt nicht mal vom Video Schiedsrichter, weil die sind die Ärmsten. Die Schiedsrichter, die müssen es wirklich austragen. Und denen mache ich keinen Vorwurf, aber so dieses ganze Gehabe. Natürlich bin ich unzufrieden als Spieler, wenn ein Schiedsrichter vielleicht eine Fehlerentscheidung trifft, aber wird auch ganz oft einfach hervorgerufen durch das Verhalten auf dem Platz, weil ich behaupte jetzt mal, jeder zweite Elfmeter ist geschunden oder von drei sind zwei, zumindest Versuche. Also jeder versucht immer irgendwie…
Die Suche nach einem Kontakt.
Genau. Und es ist kein Kontakt. Also jeder Kontakt ist nicht gleich faul. Es wird aber immer denn, und jeder sagt, oh ja, da war ein Kontakt da, das war ein Faul und so, das ist einfach gelogen. Und damit setzt du ja die Schiedsrichter so dermaßen unter Druck, dass jetzt auch der Videoschiedsrichter sagt, hier, ich sehe doch am Bildschirm, da war ein Kontakt. Also es ist faul, weil jeder will irgendwie nicht der Böse sein, der eine Fehlentscheidung trifft. Also es geht aus von den Spielern und von den Trainern auch. Wenn die Trainer natürlich jeder kämpft um seinen Job und möchte nicht oder möchte länger als 1, 8 Jahre oder so im Schnitt seinen Job behalten. Also du versuchst in jeder Situation, das Optimale rauszuholen. Das ist Profifußball, aber ich finde, die Waffen und die Mittel sind nicht mehr nicht mehr ertragbar. Also es fängt bei den Spielern an und wenn du das nicht korrigiert kriegst und das musst du in der Ausbildung korrigieren, also musst du die besten Leute in die Ausbildung stecken. Aber die besten Leute wollen nicht in der Ausbildung arbeiten, sondern in der Bundesliga, weil es da am meisten Geld zu verdienen gibt. Also das System ist renovierungsbedürftig.
Ich spüre gerade, dass ich mit dir über den aktuellen Fußball mindestens so lange reden könnte wie über den vergangenen Fußball. Das machen wir vielleicht mal an anderer Stelle. Richard, es hat mir großen Spaß gemacht mit dir, über deine 21 Jahre Bundesliga-Karriere zu sprechen. Vielen Dank dir.
Ich danke dir. Ich fand es auch toll und die Zeit ist echt im Flug vergangen. Ich habe das Gefühl, wir könnten jetzt die zweite Halbzeit anfangen.
Wir könnten wir wirklich. Wir machen das wirklich einfach noch, irgendwann mal. Euch lieben Hörerinnen und Hörern, danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Bis bald mal wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut, ciao. Das war das Rasenfunk – Tribünengespräch.
Wir gehen nun zurück um die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.